i think when we talk about uh being in  the present  we don't have to start getting into the  present when the pressure is high  we need to start practicing being in the  present  when the pressure is low it's a very  nice quote that i  read once in one of the baraks of the  indian army  which said when you sweat a lot  in times of peace you bleed less  in times of war ipl for instance cricket  now when the match is on the world  tournament's on the  the competition stops you right there  under the spot  which means the pressure is high and you  need to be focused you need to be  present  you can only do it effectively when you  learn to be present in the smaller  things of life